we're glad to have the fabulous Pamela
Geller welcome
hi welcome welcome to the battlefield
welcome to the war what happened today
is not extraordinary what happened today
is not exceptional what happened today
best illustrates what's happening and
why I wrote this book the very idea that
a human rights activist dedicated to
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom of conscience and individual
rights would be cancelled by a hotel
that hosts Mahmoud Ahmadinejad whose
promised the annihilation of the tiny
Jewish state of Israel who entertains at
the Hyatt in New York would cancel me in
caving to this leftist Islamic alliance
is indicative of how very bad the war is
worse is how few are aware of it I mean
Americans know there's something wrong
you know like like the Helen Keller and
someone move the furniture but there is
so much deception there is so much
propaganda there's so much
disinformation that that you need
glasses to see what's happening there is
a war on the truth and what is truth
truth is the recognition realities a is
a and why is it so important to silence
my voice to silence Robert Spence's
voice no need our wishes voice ayaan
Hirsi Ali Zoids guava Sultan's voice
because it's important that the truth be
kept from you and yet all you have to do
is look around and see that this is a
war in the information battle space this
is a war of information and all the
bullets and the bombs and the bloodshed
comes as a result of what happens in
this war and they have in their arsenal
the most powerful weapon of all big
media it's the reason why Obama was
elected it's the reason why you don't
know what's happening but I will
describe to you in brief detail the
stealth jihad the masking of the
workplace for example imposing Muslim
prayer times on union contracts forcing
non-muslim workers to lengthen their day
that's wrong that's imposing Islam on
the secular marketplace you have a
company like Heinz the ketchup company
by the way who's been enormously
generous to their Muslim workers not
only do they have Muslim prayer rooms
they have Muslim prayer rugs but they're
being sued why they being sued they're
being sued to stop the line stop the
line for Muslim prayer times now
understand something in Muslim countries
they don't stop the line in Iran they
don't stop during the work day to pray
they prayed before work they pray after
work why so white why do it here it's to
impose Islam on non-muslims you see the
taxicab drivers that won't pick up fares
that have alcohol that have seen I dogs
because dogs are dirty dogs are filthy
you see the US Treasury Department the
US Treasury Department giving seminars
and Sharia finance a week after we
nationalized some banks now you'll say
to me what's wrong with showing a
finance Pamela I'm glad you asked me
that question it has to be hello which
means investing in certain industries is
forbidden pork Alcohol Tobacco and some
forms of entertainment well those are
whole American industries do you want to
use your taxpayer dollars to stop whole
American industries there is the masking
of the public schools where they have
prayer spaces for some children they
don't have it for Christians they don't
have it for Jews they don't have it the
Hindus they don't have it for
zoroastrians there's also the Islamist
sizing of the public school curriculum
where they are instituting whole
curriculum curriculum is dedicated to
Islam but not to the 1400 years of a 270
million victims of G
patty Wars land appropriations cultural
annihilations and enslavement it's
complete sawa it's complete whitewashing
now I did fault your governor for this
Governor Perry instituted along with
agha khan a complete and Iran
screenshots of all of the lessons don't
listen to me judge for yourself that's
another thing you're going to have to do
you're going to have to do your own
homework because you are being lied to
and I don't see curriculums in the
public schools for Christians I don't
see curriculums in the public schools
for Jews or for anybody else and for
those of you that have children in the
school and who see this who see this and
parents see it look just two weeks ago I
was contacted by a parent and a
columnist in the parents cool they had a
lesson the lesson was my name is a
schema and oddly was a young girl in
Saudi Arabia and the lesson is about how
wonderful it is to be a young girl in
Saudi Arabia hello and how wonderful it
is polygamy is and how wonderful it is
to be the second wife because the first
wife she has to do all the dinners she
has to go out socially and she's not a
fleam is not a social girl and how great
that she doesn't have to do it and she
could be stay-at-home wife and she goes
on to say that she loves the burka and
she feels sorry for all those quote
horribly immodestly dressed Western
women and the last line of this lesson
in the public school of Georgia is how
fortunate we are to have the Sharia now
understand something I know how I'm
painted I know I'm painted as a racist
Islamophobic anti-muslim biggin I know
that if you talk about this even this
much this under ases Islamophobic
anti-muslim vega to why because this is
the way they silenced anybody that
speaks to this issue this is the way
they enforce the blasphemy laws of the
sharia in this country the media refuses
to touch this subject in Muslim
countries blasphemers anyone who offends
Islam
anyone who insults Islam anyone who
criticizes Islam is put today here in
the West Europe Canada and the US your
character is assassinated you are
demonized you are marginalized you're a
rendered radioactive you are cancelled
at a small hotel in a small Texas town
regularly you must be aware of what is
happening to you have any of you been to
Europe lately you want a cautionary tale
look to Europe this is not anti-muslim I
speak for all human beings including
Muslims especially Muslims who fled
Sharia who fled Muslim countries to
escape the most oppressive and radical
ideology on the face of the earth who
speaks for them do you ever hear from
them do you ever hear from them in the
media does PBS ever do a special when a
young Christian convert out of Islam
teenage girl left Islam and it was
afraid to tell her family but was outed
by Hamas the norm asked in Ohio who was
spying on her told her parents that she
had converted out of Islam and a father
threatened to kill her so she ran away
and I remember when I first got the
story because some people in Ohio sent
me the story and they're like they were
from her friends said we're worried
about her because she converted out of
Islam so I remember saying to Spencer I
said you think she's alive anything she
got out he said they never get out so
imagine my joy really when she was found
in Florida and what ensued was this case
to bring this girl back to this deadly
household she was painted as some
radical crazy Christian fundamentalist
it was disgusting she was a young sweet
girl virtuous straight-a student
meanwhile millions of girls run away
they had doing drugs they're selling
their bodies nobody's looking for them
but this girl the sweet little virgin
straight-a student
the whole country is looking for her
well they drugged her back they did drag
her back to Florida I mean they did drag
her back to Ohio and mind you while I
was in Florida I would see these buses
these busts heads I'm sure you've seen
them in Texas why aslam come to aslam
privatizing for aslam and I saw these
buses and I said what about those that
want to leave Islam so I sought an air
campaign I took their ad and I said
leaving Islam is your family threatening
you is there a fatwah on your head got a
refuge from Islam com well let me tell
you yeah that's right they need help
they need help and there's no network
for them they need safe houses and it's
not just like a let's say I'm a big of a
wife that's beaten needs to escape a
husband here many times they need to
escape not just their families but the
mosque in the community they need help
nobody speaks for them and when they do
come out like a replica Barry they're
completely destroyed in the media
completely Nonie Darwish a former Muslim
Waka Sultana former Muslim even work a
former Muslim systematically destroyed
their voices I've never heard on college
campuses and of course that became a
story to the bus ads became a story
because it was offensive to Muslims I
said I wasn't offensive to Muslims if I
did an ad for housewives that were
beaten it's like all the husband's
saying hey I'm offended
am I wrong when they say that I paint
all Muslims with a broad brush it's not
true first of all excuse me but I don't
have to congratulate somebody for not
wanting to kill me I expect that that's
my bar but clearly there's a problem
with this ideology there have been over
18,000 Islamic attacks since 911 each
one with the improv matter of a Muslim
cleric each one with a mosque behind it
but nobody will talk about that the
whole jihad against Israel if you've
read the Quran you know what's Islamic
you hatred it's part of the DNA of Islam
and this whole narrative of demonizing
this tiny little stain nine miles at its
wide surrounded by these ginormous
Muslim lands and it's about land you
can't make these lies up there so big
and impossible to believe the very
existence of Israel is an attack on
Muslims it is an attack on Islam they
will never let Israel exists never let
Israel live in peace ever they did it
before 67 they did it before there was
the establishment of the State of Israel
in 1948 there were Palestinian Muslims
there were Palestinian Jews living in
Palestine which is a word that the
Romans conjured up to humiliate Israel
to humiliate the Jewish people they
changed it to Palestine but the mufti of
Jerusalem the leader of the Muslim the
leader of the Muslim world was
conducting programs against the Jewish
people in 21 29 36 and then he hooked up
with Hitler and he lived in Berlin from
1941 to 1945 he raised Muslim armies in
Bosnia and was responsible for the death
of four hundred thousand women Jewish
women and children are your children
taught about the role of Islam during
the Holocaust and the show up no they
are not Charlie the Nazis have been
demonized and vilified so why do they
get a free pass why is the history books
whitewashed why because
it's the Sharia do not offend Islam do
not insult Islam even if it's the truth
my friend haired builders was put on
trial in the Netherlands for hate speech
for his short film fitna which was just
a small too short documentary on the
terrorist attack and what inspired them
911 311 77 and he was on trial of hate
speech and the crime was it doesn't
matter according to the dungeon Criminal
Court they said it doesn't matter if
you're telling the truth what matters is
against the law what law the Sharia
who's enforcing the Sharia is this
accidental it's not accidental at the UN
the largest block of countries is the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation
previously called the Organization of
Islamic Conference they are 56 countries
plus the Palestinian Authority 56
countries that boat as one block and
they have one objective and that is to
install the Sharia across the world they
are the modern-day universal Caliphate
builders was put on trial because of the
OIC mandates they are very powerful in
the UN they are very powerful in the EU
and here you had the president united
states president barack hussein obama
skull sponsoring a resolution at the UN
to restrict free speech it's
unbelievable and the media tells you
nothing the meeting here is no evil see
no evil speak no evil and how deeply
we've been infiltrated when you have a
pentagon when you have a Department of
Defense issue a final report on the Fort
Hood jihadi a devout Muslim who came out
on Grand Rounds made a powerpoint
presentation on Grand Rounds that sews
extinct I use it sometimes who is
wearing the garb of the shahid the
morning of his jihad who was screaming
Allah Akbar which means Allah is greater
greater than what greater than your God
it's supremacist Allah is greater was
giving our qur'an's the morning of his
jihad had soldier of Allah on his
business card said soldier of Allah and
nowhere in the in the DoD's report today
mention religious
nation how long do you think that you're
going to avoid the inevitable in this
operation fetal position the Department
of Justice is creating whole Muslim
majority legislative districts for
voting based on the racial paradigm they
created for districting districting
based on race do you know about that the
Department of Justice scuttled the
prosecution's of the 300 groups names in
the largest terrorist funding trial in
our nation's history the Holy Land trial
groups Muslim Brotherhood groups who
according to an internal captured
document entered into that case their
stated goal is to eliminate and destroy
Western civilization from within and
sabotage it's miserable house so that
Allah is victorious their stated goal
their words and instead the Department
of Justice shoes a school district who
didn't allow a teacher a new teacher a
probationary teacher the only math lab
teacher on their staff to go on Hajj she
wanted to take a month off they said you
can't you're our only math lab teacher
well hold her sued the school by the way
they settled she gets 75 k plus legal
expenses this is happening every day
this is happening every day there's no
hate here listen I'm a lover why don't
why am I doing this why do I subject
myself to this I do it for art for music
for love and for freedom because I love
this country because I grew up so
completely and utterly freedom when I
was a kid we used to say to each other
it's a free country isn't it it's a free
country you don't hear that anymore
because it's inherently not and I do see
an a leftist Islamic alliance and
clearly Muslims are welcome here this
idea of anti-muslim backlash another
deception another lie according to the
recent most recent
from the FBI anti-muslim crime is down
to its lowest levels since nine eleven
anti-semetic crime is at historic
world-wide levels you ever hear about
that no but they're constantly every
time there's a terrorist attack what's
the knee-jerk reaction antic Muslim
booted into some backlash no no people
die can we talk about that please this
is a war in a battle of information and
the media is complicit the media is
dangerous and that's why each one of you
is so critical in this book I whatever
your issue is each one of you has a
different issue some of you may not have
an issue that's okay too but if you are
fighting for example we fought the
ground zero mosque we fought the ground
zero mosque and we won oh yeah
and for those of you that say well you
know what's the big deal let me tell you
what the big deal was a 15-story mega
mosque in a building that was destroyed
in those attacks when the landing gear
crashed through the roof is ground zero
that mega mosque 15 story by the name of
Cordoba another another like another
stabbed in the eye cordoba is iconic of
islamic conquest over the West when in
7-eleven Muslim armies invaded Spain
which was a collection of Christian
kingdoms and maybe it was a golden era
for the Muslims but it wasn't a golden
era for the Christians and the Jews that
lived on the dhimmitude on with denied
basic human rights and was the site of
the very first Jewish program and the
second Jewish program that's the name of
the ground zero mosque and let me tell
you something else that has never been
in the history of Islam a mosque of
reconciliation and healing built on the
site of a jihadi attack but we have tens
of thousands of examples of Islamic
supremacists mosques Troy uncle mosques
built on the cherished sites of
conquered lands the most obvious of
course is the first temple this and the
second temple the Dome of the rock the
Saint Sophia the most exquisite and
extraordinary extraordinary church in
history is a mosque that should be a
church give that back give that back and
tens of thousands of Hindu temples tens
of thousands of Hindu temples so you're
going to tell me that a 15-story mega
mosque looking down on the sacred ground
that was covered in blood and ash is
reconciliation and healing and even if
they didn't know let's just say they
know now
just because you can build something
doesn't mean you should and even look at
the Pope when they were going to build a
church across from Auschwitz and this
caused an enormous amount of of grief
the Pope would do the church did he have
to know its decency it's human
compassion where's the reciprocity we're
constantly being schooled about this
hypersensitivity in the Muslim world do
not offend aslam do not run the Danish
cartoons and no media Rambo's Danish
cartoons and then when South Park did an
episode where they put Mohammed in a
huggy bear costume because you can't
show Mohammed they got there was a photo
on their head and Comedy Central bleeds
out the word Mohammed have we lost our
collective minds gets better so now a
little girl in Seattle young probably
liberal it was a cartoonist she loves
the show Comedy Central loves to show
South Park she says well led to
everybody draw mohammed a i guess she
was thinking they can't kill us all and
within 24 hours she's got a photo on her
head now she was clearly out of her
element she didn't know what she was
doing so she would track with what she
retracted never ever retract the smell
of weakness is like blood two shots not
only did the FBI insist that she go into
witness protection this cartoon is how
to give up honey ha job ha home at her
own expense and I'm going to ask you how
many here have ever heard of Molly
Norris one hand she should be the poster
girl for free speech she should be on
the front page of every newspaper in
America and you haven't even heard of
her it's outrageous it is outrageous
the reason why I wrote this book is
because you can fight if you look at the
ground zero mosque you had the
president's supporting it you not only
had a mayor who vocally supported it in
the most the scariest most clueless way
if we don't build the mosque the
terrorists will win what it would have
been mega on the hudson that's what that
would have been up on the hudson you
know when they find these jackets the
we've been getting you know the
Hezbollah has been using the narco
transit routes well you should know that
they're not go transit routes in tech in
Mexico why do you think you're seeing an
increase in beheaded decapitations what
do you think that's coming from that's a
religious that's a religious ritual
slaughter you were not it you didn't
have that in Mexico before even this
this latest attack the Iranian attack on
on the Saudis and Israel interesting
that's a very interesting that some
people say model don't understand that
let me tell you what that was all about
there's an avid a listen the Islamic
world the Islamic supremacists world
sees senses the vacuum there's a vacuum
because America's abdicated her roll
under this president he's relinquishing
American sovereignty in my book my first
book the post American presidency the
Obama administration's war on America I
outlined his abdication of American
hegemony evil loves a vacuum so there's
always this constant battle in Islam
between the Shia and the Sunni so the
very idea that Iran which is the leader
of the shield world would execute the
Saudi ambassador on American soil their
number one patron and Ally and blow up
the embassy and of course the Jews too
because it's not a party if you don't
kill the Jews would be a huge message
aloud message to the world of supremacy
and domination and again I applaud the
Florida tax how many attacks have
had in this country and what bothers me
is that just because they don't get get
it off doesn't mean it wasn't serious is
this some kind of a disconnect there's
some kind of a disconnect we're
constantly forwarding Islamic attacks
and you're not allowed you know let us
say the word jihad if you ask anybody on
the street what are we doing who are we
fighting in Iraq and Afghanistan they
can't answer you it's very simple it's
jihad that does it it's not complicated
and Obama partnering with the Taliban he
it's shocking they're gassing girls
schools that we're building gassing them
and where are the Liberals where the
left what i mean when i see when i go to
these anti-israel rallies and I see
queers for Palestine I got it I am still
stunned by that you don't they do to
quiz in Palestine they take a razor all
around the face and they pull the face
off
you know what they do to gays in Iran
they hang them in the public square by
on cherry pickers and leave them that
iraq so that you get the message and we
are aware and we're where's the left
incredible to me that the left would
shut down the Liberals which again
another word that's been completely
inverted every word means the opposite
of what it means occupation Chicago is
holding a peaceful protest okay peaceful
protests with a calling for the
destruction of Israel and Obama's power
by sheep calidius speaking a virulent
notorious june eight ER and insider of
to genocide and again i have to say you
know I I don't get it where y is in
America asking Obama why we're sending
troops into Africa Africa dis lautering
Christians in Egypt by your hand by your
hand because Obama had invited the
Muslim Brotherhood to his speech in
Cairo in june of two thousand nine four
months five months after he took office
they were outlawed shaker adavi was
outlawed there was a reason I'm sorry I
don't think I mubark was the bad guy
that everyone painted him out to be
perfect hardly am I going to show them
not but there are degrees he was the
only us-allied Muslim country to make a
peace with Israel and you may not have
liked it but it's done its it's stuck
when I was in Israel dedicating a grove
of trees to the victims of honor
killings worldwide they was shelling
Israel from Egypt first time in 30 years
have you heard about that the 30
Christians that was slaughtered last
week three hundred hurt send some troops
there I don't believe in sending troops
by the way unless it's a matter of
national security I don't know what
we're doing in Africa I don't know what
we're doing in Libya what we're doing in
Libya you know what Libby is now Libby's
falling to the hands of al Qaeda and
jihadists is Qaddafi a good guy hell no
is al Qaeda and jihad better worse worse
there are degrees there are degrees of
damage there are degrees of evil you
going to me his foreign policy he saw it
with the enemy every time and it's not
just Obama we have been infiltrated but
I hear that Heidi teeth in the audience
is going to be running for office I say
Baruch Hashem this is what we need to do
you need to get politicians and office
who get it allow your pants Hannah was
running I don't care if you don't live
it hela is in North Carolina send him
money he gets it I I have to tell you
that there's no way you're going to
escape this issue and the more you avoid
it it's like you're supposed to play a
tennis match and you don't show up what
do you think the match didn't happen no
you forfeited the game that's what's
happening the fact that we protested
that mosque and we would not let up and
how do we get the word out how did I get
40,000 people to ground 0 on September
11th let me tell you something I've been
writing that story since november two
thousand 2010 you did it you made that
the number one story of 2010 and the
number one international story of 2010
the media wouldn't touch that story but
everybody kept sending around these
little stories look fancier my brooms
rumah squad and then by first rally
which I expected a couple hundred people
and we got like eight thousand people
somebody took a post of mine and just
took the pictures didn't a link text
nothing just the pitches up against the
mosque and that email went viral I was
getting my own pictures hey did you see
this
like 20 times a day and that's when the
media woke up so do not think for one
second that what you do is not important
do not believe for one second that the
individual can change the course of
human events because the individual can
and does and will change the course of
human events this is a unique and
brilliant and magnificent experiment
America in human history oh it really is
we're in it so we can't really see the
beauty of it but America is the first
moral government in the history of man
based on individual rights yes it
deserves
the first and everything noble and
brilliant and magnificent we achieved
was a logical fidelity to that principle
that's what I'm fighting for I'm not
fighting against anything I will oppose
anyone that dares to take my freedom I
will not live for the sake of another
man and I will not ask another man to
live for the sake of me and it's
important that you get involved in this
fight you say how well I will tell you
how I'm glad you asked me that question
when you wake up in the morning and you
rub the sleep from your eyes you first
thing you ask yourself what am I going
to do today save the Republic I don't
care if it's just sending an article
around when you throw that little pebble
in the water you set it around she sends
it around he sends it around that's it
we are our own media we are the media of
one and I know it's difficult and I know
it's a leap frog and I know listen you
see the Muslim Brotherhood groups are
actually getting the FBI to stop talking
to anyone critical of Islam no matter
how heralded the scholar from even
Warrick you know to Robert Spencer so
there what is this and then in the
schools when your children are taught
that curriculum you are dis arming the
children you are disarming law
enforcement and it all comes down to you
it doesn't have to be this way it's
certainly winnable you will not like
what comes after America you won't so I
left some time for question and answers
there is so much more that I could tell
you I like I didn't even discuss the
litigation jihad like the 10 million
dollar lawsuit that was filed against me
by Griffey Barry's parents attorney the
Christian convert I told you about that
escaped I was a very big public
averaging advocate for her ten million
dollar lawsuit and if David Yerushalmi
and Robert muse of the rabbit more Law
Center son lose guys a check didn't
represent me pro bono over three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in legal fees
he dropped the case because there was no
case and the two didn't did the judge
what ensues total freedom of speech it
was a total freedom of speech issue I
had filed a motion to
this they never ruled on it they never
ruled on it you must be proactive right
now in the New York subway system they
are running ads that call for the end of
US aid to Israel there are anti-semitic
out there clearly anti-semitic ads as if
the you the US aid is somehow an
impediment to peace again the big you
know Hitler called it the big lie tell
the big lie often enough it becomes the
truth so I submitted my ads this is my
head with one line of text in any war
between the civilized man and the savage
side with the civilized man support
Israel defeat jihad
yeah they rejected my ax i'm suing
that's true i am i'm suing so so yeah so
you need to understand you're not bad
for loving good cuz that's what it is
it's the hatred of the good for being
the good you're not bad for do not let
them shut you up this is the key the key
is shutting people up read the Quran and
don't buy a whitewash version the
closest version in English is Dawood da
WOD penguin books read it for yourself
but every time they cite Quranic chapter
and verse every time they blowing
themselves up that they're not all
misunderstandings of Islam I assure you
the reason why I wrote the book is you
do need to know how to fight the fight
it's it's it's difficult you know the
media is your enemy so when you're doing
these things if they talk to you outside
they're looking to get you to say one
thing that they can parse and then paint
the whole well your tea party do I have
to tell you how they demeaned and wide
and libeled and defamed this movement of
righteous people I know I've spoken at
enough tea parties to know that you will
save America oh yes and how they're
clamming up this movement in Wall Street
you should see I live there you should
see it is vile the signs are vile they
are attacking the police and then when
the police got to push them back that's
the shot you see on the front page of
the New York Times trust me on this if
they took first of all there have been
1500 arrests right trust me it should be
10,000 they're not arresting them
they'll get away with such lawlessness
if any of you guys did one-tenth of what
they were doing you'd all be in jail
they're getting this they really are and
now they're muro marauding mobs all over
the city they're gone from Times Square
next they going to do and and it's
interesting listen I wasn't too unhappy
because Zuccotti Park which drew my
permit for my ground zero mosque uh
rally on jun 6 d-day yeah but they were
true it now let me say that my people
they leave the place clean up then when
they got there you could eat off the
street ok now that same park that said
well no were the only these one which
worth drawing it is because you know we
don't want to get involved in politics
that's where these dregs have set up
home and I say drugs they have the most
beautiful like flower pots that a marble
destroyed I mean they destroyed this
park oh yeah oh yeah so be careful be
careful how and that's why I want to say
too high it you know be careful who you
side with because that's going to come
back to bite you the left to the left
thanks why does the left love this I
know why the left loves this first
because the left always aligns itself
with whatever totalitarian ideology
there is of the day if it wasn't
Stalinism it was communism wasn't
communism it was a National Socialist
Workers Party who is the National
Socialist Workers Party the Nazi Party
they say was ranked No wasn't it was
left and now this the Sharia is the
ultimate weapon in which to control the
people the ultimate weapon that's why I
think they like it the restriction of
free speech the love loves to shut us up
so they use that they don't believe me
they will be eaten alive they have no
idea they think the day I know what
they're thinking they think look we'll
just use these will use these tools they
are the ones that are being used just
look at Europe Europe has no go zones
the police cannot enter firefighters
kind of enter unless there's a staged
incident where at stage two law the
police in attack the police brutally
attack the police and that's how they
get the message of course and if you go
into these towns if you drive through
toll men on the street women are covered
from soup to nuts like that Kim
Kardashian wearing a burqa in Dubai I
ask you no let me tell you why it's so
incredibly reprehensible she's an
Armenian she's Armenian now the mufti of
Jerusalem who I told you about the
leader of the Muslim world that you know
was responsible for the death of
hundreds of thousands of Jews you know
where he cut his teeth he was an officer
in the Ottoman Empire the Ottoman
Ottoman army he cut his teeth at the
armenian genocide which resulted as you
know in the death of two
two million Armenian Christians so I
urge you to do your homework I urge you
to talk to your kids there are no young
people here they're like this mindless
generation of bogs not all not all I see
young here yeah look both one two
thousand i know i know i love you
because it takes incredible courage for
you to be here it takes incredible it
cannot be easy and i think they are
attracted to this movement because this
is like the Woodstock you know like when
I was a kid go see Stevie Wonder you
know they were great you know music
festivals what do they have lady google
what do they have I do and that's all I
have any of your music I mean I like
something it's not a generational thing
there's no music it's bom bom pom pom
pom I mean if there's no music so this
is like become they're down there
they're making one of their down there
they're smoking pot and they're being
used ill-used in the work now of course
it's now they want all college students
to occupy college campuses take over
college campuses and they have their
list of demands this is not going away
this is not going to be pretty this is
going to get ugly this is Obama's way of
shifting the blame of incurring more
debt than all the previous presidents
combined routing the American economy
shifting the blame to the businessman
again the big giant light let's blame
business for business it's the
demonization of a successful and the
exaltation of failure that's what you're
witnessing here it is the opposite of
America the opposite of America this
class warfare is ugly and divisive and
it's going to get uglier and you're
going to see that the enemy of my enemy
is my friends are you going to see the
aligning of Islamic groups with
left-wing groups and it's going to get
very ugly and I'm telling you there's no
such thing as being a passive bystander
because you will be collateral damage
and when you go to sleep at night and
you think about your children ok I put
some money away from my children I have
an insurance policy oh now
their future is so dim at this moment I
am not engaging in hyperbole it's up to
us I want to thank you very much for
coming out I want to thank you very much
for suffering the slings and arrows of
the asshats outside and I I pray I pray
that you continue the fight
you